Russia's war on Ukraine dominated
today's G20 Summit talks President Biden
is meeting with other world leaders in
Indonesia delegates discuss whether
Ukraine should seek a peace deal at this
time Nancy Cordis is in Bali not a bad
place to be traveling with the president
Nancy good morning I know there's a lot
of work going on
there is Gail this Summit is a gathering
of the world's 20 largest economies and
so as you might expect they have a lot
of influence in world affairs and so
Ukraine's President Vladimir zielinski
addressed this group by video and he
urged them not to ask him to compromise
with Russia at this time he compared
Ukraine's recent liberation of the city
of Carson to D-Day he said it could be a
turning point in this war and pointedly
he referred to the Gathering here as the
g19 instead of the G20 meant as a snub
to Russian President Vladimir Putin who
chose not to attend this Gathering now
in an interview U.S treasury secretary
Janet Yellen told me she believes the
Chinese who are also here are getting
closer to condemning Russia's Invasion I
also asked her about the global shortage
of diesel fuel and what it could mean
for America
do you believe that the U.S will have
enough diesel fuel to make it through
the winter
well hopefully I believe there will be
but the East Coast really faces some
shortages and low inventories so
um we're keeping a close eye in
monitoring that
she said she also hopes that diesel fuel
prices don't go up again because if they
do then prices for all kinds of goods
will likely go up as well because diesel
fuel is so heavily used in
transportation so she says that that's
something that she's going to be
watching very closely could obviously
make packages this winter around
Christmas time more expensive Nate
that's Dakota zambali thank you